all right so we've been talking about
the later stages of the american civil
war and in the last videos we talked
about the battle of gettysburg and the
gettysburg address
which happened in november
of 1863
as abraham lincoln went to the site of
the battle of gettysburg to dedicate the
cemetery that was being built there to
hold the battlefield dead which numbered
in the thousands
so in the next few videos i'd like to
take you through the last stages
of the civil war
starting with late 1863 so if you think
back to the very beginning of the war
the north strategy was
called the anaconda plan and the
anaconda is a kind of snake that
squeezes its victims and so the plan of
the north was going to be to squeeze the
south by completely surrounding it and
then not allowing anything to get in or
out so the south would have no choice
but to surrender as they ran out of
supplies and so the anaconda plan
is going fairly well
in this late period of the war so now
you recall that
they were going to blockade
the atlantic ocean so that
the south couldn't ship
any of its cotton or receive any
supplies from europe so that's not
happening and to take control of the
mississippi river which goes here
and so the other reason why abraham
lincoln was so happy after the north won
the battle of gettysburg is because
ulysses s grant had just taken vicksburg
which meant that the union had control
of the mississippi river so you can see
that the plan
to surround the south is going pretty
well and this uh this blockade extended
all the way down around florida
so the last
real area here that the union needs to
control is this sort of middle region
here and you know that these are the
border states so there's still slavery
allowed in places like kentucky and
tennessee
and maryland
and another thing that's kind of hard to
see from this map is that there are
mountains here
this is the appalachian mountain range
and so this is going to be a difficult
area to strategize through so thanks to
this mountain range there are two real
main theaters of war during the civil
war there's the eastern theater of the
war which is over here
and that includes a lot of the battles
that are going to take place in this
shenandoah
valley area of virginia and through
georgia
so kind of the the tidewater piedmont
region of the east is one of the main
areas where battle takes place during
the civil war but the other theater is
this western theater
and that includes the mississippi river
and these key border states of kentucky
and tennessee so when last we left off
with the battle of gettysburg robert e
lee who is the commander of the armies
for the confederacy had made an attempt
to
invade the north and got as far as
southern pennsylvania
where
the union troops
led by general george meade turned the
confederates away
and so now they're headed back to
virginia
and there's going to be some really
fierce fighting here
in this northern part of virginia known
as the wilderness campaign
as lee retreats to richmond
so that's the eastern theater and i'll
draw the blue line that's going to be
following them here
as well
now in the western theater of the war
ulysses s grant
has just provided a major victory by
taking vicksburg
and now controlling all of the
mississippi river so abraham lincoln has
been
looking for a great general to lead his
armies now lee has been the commander of
the confederate armies this entire time
but the union army has had a multitude
of commanders from winfield scott to
george mcclellan but in ulysses s grant
lincoln finally finds his general and so
after the
victory at the siege of vicksburg grant
goes up into tennessee
and finally captures tennessee so he
takes chattanooga
and firmly puts tennessee in control of
the union so look how well the anaconda
strategy is going now we've got
tennessee we're almost there so after
taking chattanooga lincoln makes grant
the commander of all the union armies he
is the general in chief and it's going
to be grant who ultimately leads the
union to victory and when he meets up
with lee
as he will do
once he heads to richmond and then later
appomattox he's going to be the one who
really ends the war by forcing lee's
surrender but we'll get to that all
right so that's 1863
the period at which grant becomes
commander of the armies lee is turned
away from his second invasion of the
north and flees to richmond
and the stage is set for the final year
and a little bit more of the war which
we'll get to in the next video